welcome also to our vice chairs Minister
Tovar from Costa Rica minister of Connor
from New Zealand and a very special
welcome to the prime minister of Ukraine
as well as to Indonesia's the Minister
of Finance
and India's G20 Sherpa Amitabh cand who
are joining us virtually this morning
colleagues friends is an uncertain time
for our economists
and for the global rules
which we released this morning
global economy has begun to improve
albeit at this point
remains fragile
risks remain tilted to the downside
we are yet to unwind the inflation
problems
and tried restrictions
in this environment
policy makers around the world
must continue to do both
respond intelligently these are
short-term pressures
while resolutely pursuing
structural priorities
we need to boost sustainable and
inclusive growth
promote more competitive markets and
continue to liberalize
investment regimes we must address the
impact of population
and realize
gender equality and women's economic
empowerment
we must drive digital and green
transformation
and we must preserve and improve the
ability of Nations to work together
and by strengthening the global
Mississippi
functions
economic
[Music]
and perform
through International
um
have very much stood the test of time
and these principles have never
been more important
um
the people of Ukraine are literally on
the front lines
we continue to be horrified
caused by Russia's Wars
the homes destroyed
nowadays terrible disaster distractions
continuing Russian aggression
you have our very strong solidarity and
students reform
do you development
and prosperity
realize gender equality
must remain the problem
the oecd will build on our gender
recommendations
to address digital divides and to manage
potential adverse effects of technology
and sustainability technology
organizations
region
a key driver of global economic growth
the green transformation
a conclusion
we need more dialogue and cooperation to
find Solutions
it's kind of cooperation
our principles
and our organizational methodologies
the instruments you decide to put in
place the agenda you set out for the
year ahead and the contributions you are
making over the next two days
continue to provide a platform for
evidence by spiritual learning and
positive International devices
and evidence-based policy
recommendations to help governments
immediate challenges
yeah
of ensuring
policies foreign
[Applause]
foreign
good morning ministers ambassadors
friends
colleagues welcome to today's OCD
ministerial council meeting
securing a resilient future
values and Global Partnerships is both
timely and important I'm honored to
representative UK as chair of this
year's meeting and we have put together
an ambitious forward-looking agenda that
addresses our most serious
Global pandemic demonstrated the
importance of resilience
Diversified Supply chains
Russia's illegal invasion of us
[Music]
security and economic development in the
post-war era originally
[Music]
this year opens a new chapter in the
years
today
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
always at the Forefront
and we must support
hosting in London
the world's economy
disrupting Global Supply chains
free trade
and we need to work together to ensure
our world is changing
diagnose disease
yes
The Forum will find Opportunities
or find its opportunities and mitigate
the challenges of immersive Technologies
Quantum and biology
Innovation ushers of our societies
towards New Frontiers it unlocks
previously
improvements it will be Central to
ensuring we can adapt to environmental
change
in our discussion on future Frontiers
and Energy Futures we'll explore these
issues in more depth and I look forward
to my colleague Grant chaps Secretary of
State Foreign energy
uh
[Music]
for the whole world
thank you
[Applause]
distinguished Secretary General
distinguished chair of the ministerial
Council distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
yesterday's Russian Federation caused
one of the most significant
environmental catastrophes in Europe in
recent decades around three o'clock in
the morning Russian forces detonated the
dam and Machinery Hall of the kafoka
hydroelectric power station this act of
Terror resulted in a bridge of the
Kahoka Reservoir unleashing a torrent of
water down the nipple River the
hydroelectric power station has been
irreversibly destroyed and this is
greater harm and future treat caused by
the Russian Act of Terror lies in the
ecological Devastation
dozens of towns and villages
irrigation system of Southern regions
will
cease leading to drought and growth
of Global Food security
hydroelectric power station at least 150
tons of machine oil have leaked into the
river with a risk of an additional 300
tons
nuclear power plant and force the
aggressor to be held accountable for its
us
I'm sorry I couldn't join you in person
today
circumstances in our country
I'm sure you understand
of our appreciation and commitment to
all of you on this occasion I would like
to express my sincere gratitude
and our International Partners
comprehensive support of Ukraine in this
difficult times
foreign
[Music]
is
thank you so much
[Applause]
we now invite to the podium Vice chair
Manuel Tovar minister of foreign trade
of Costa Rica
[Applause]
good morning Mr Secretary General
Mr cleverly Damien dear ministers dear
friends Mr Prime Minister
it is such an honor to be back to
What I Call my second home the oecd
and it is also an honor to coach her
alongside with the United Kingdom and
New Zealand this year's 2023 Ministry
council meeting
Costa Rica stands as an example that the
size of a country does not
determine nor should limit
its aspirations
and the role it can play in helping to
address present Global challenges
throughout our history
Costa Rica has taken Visionary difficult
decisions foreign
[Music]
technological advance
it's
its Global reach and influence is
we wish this MCM to be a success and we
look forward to today's discussions
[Applause]
we now invite to the podium the vice
chair Damien O'Connor Minister for trade
and Export growth for New Zealand
[Applause]
Secretary General
um
foreign
excellencies it's wonderful to be here
among so many friends
the language of our indigenous people of
air to Aurora New Zealand
it is my privilege to be back at the
oecd to Vice chair dmcm under the
leadership of the United Kingdom and
Costa Rica
newest member especially this year while
celebrating the 50th anniversary of the
oecd 50 years ago when New Zealand
joined the oecd community as its 24th
member and we probably could not
anticipate the pace at which the global
Landscapes
today we're meeting in the context of an
intensifying geopolitical
environmental protectionism
we're filling these impacts on our
livelihoods
in see him theme of securing a resilient
future matters the most
shared belief in an open and transparent
markets democracy human rights and the
rule of law providers
is to ensure
approaches Virginia
[Music]
[Applause]
please turn to the screen as we invite
India's
in the capacity of the G20 presidency to
make his remarks
um
ladies and gentlemen uh
one family one future presidency
the best practices
a multilateral institutions
foreign
ladies
this is an opportunity foreign
[Music]
countries in the peak of covet crisis it
was India that received billions worth
of Investments
for a sustainable inclusive and
resilience
thank you very much
[Applause]